represión policial y restricción a la
libertad de prensa esta es la
combinación de factores que mantienen a
mi amar en medio de un mar de tensiones
a la creciente ola de protestas contra
el golpe de estado del primero de
febrero y la detención de manifestantes
se sumó este martes el cierre de cinco
medios de comunicación independientes y
el arresto de varios periodistas en
estas imágenes de una cámara de
seguridad conocidas en las últimas horas
se aprecia como los agentes de las
fuerzas de seguridad desplegados en el
centro de rangún acercaron la zona para
impedir que los manifestantes que
participaron en las marchas del lunes
pudieran escapar aunque finalmente
entrada la mañana a los cientos de
ciudadanos reprimidos pudieron abandonar
los puntos en los que se refugiaron
luego de que las embajadas de reino
unido canadá y eeuu en mi amar exigieron
la liberación de las áreas controladas
horas antes la preocupación por el
lanzamiento de granadas de aturdimiento
y disparos llevó a líderes religiosos a
intentar interceder todos nos
arrodillamos para hacerles nuestra
solicitud dijeron que tomarían medidas
enérgicas contra la protesta como dije
no quiero dar ningún problema aquí y no
puedo irme si la policía no se va les
rogué que no les dispararan a los niños
porque me preocupa la gente del hospital
cerca
y los residentes que viven por aquí
al menos 40 personas fueron detenidas en
la última jornada de movilizaciones con
las que miles de ciudadanos piden que se
restablezca la democracia y que se
respeten los resultados de las
elecciones de noviembre se estima que
más de 60 ciudadanos han perdido la vida
en las marchas y que cerca de 34
profesionales de medios de comunicación
han sido detenidos desde el
levantamiento militar por lo que la onu
ha insistido en la máxima contención de
las fuerzas de seguridad y el respeto a
la protesta pacífica